bon alors maintenant j'accueille trois
personnes d'un coup c'est à dire c'est à
dire
calixthe beyala charlie et les jus ainsi
vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y j'te
jure c'est comment ça c'est une bâtisse
avait dit tu vas c'est un mec bon sur un
sol et fougasses alors la sq alors c'est
d'abord bonsoir qualité va bien ça va
mais on a droit de fumer réussi les
invités peuvent fumer bien sûr c'est des
animateurs qui peut on me dit en régie
que même les invités et d un petit peu
des soucis signifie bah oui elle c'est
sa filiale ecs âgées christine landes
sur le clean week lessines d'accord et
c'est bien sûr fait rire mais comme tu
veux estimé absolument pesté puisse
écrire ou trois entraînements et m6 et
m6 à membres mais attention à moi je la
ramène pas ça va les gars savent rien
bon alors après on va écouter ce que
vous avez chanté après
à 12 ans cousine huawei polak effondré
ça y est complètement je voulais laisser
entre jeunes hormis chez les enfants
s'amusent à 12 ans thiery latt avec nous
vous en est très heureux de vous avoir
non mais vraiment quoi j'allais me
coucher savez je suis un costaud mois
mais non histoire écoulés ce genre de
questions finisse si vous allez vous
coucher tôt l'on veut croire des dieux
mais c'est le cas vous partirez l'agent
avant la chanson si vous voulez non je
vois une couche est vraiment bon mais
celle attendue mais chez nous on était
heureux de nous avoir fait loin clavel
ai dit je ne veux pas être censuré un
truc de tilly qu'on puisse repasser en
dessous même pas un truc comme ça vous
dit arthur repas sont les enfants de la
télé dans le dix ans parce que je n'ai
pas ce qui va passer à web et dans la la
je vous dis je
je n'ai plus rien à dire je trouve vous
amuser comme des jeunes fous et je
trouve que c'est pas la peine que je
reste là c'est pas à cause de calixte
bonjour je pense qu'elles n'ont rien
n'est pas à cause de canicule
j ai déjà dieudonné cas pas voulu venir
à cause de sébastien c'est toujours un
peu peur quand je la vois pas ce qu'elle
sort des grosses conneries alors ça met
de mauvaise humeur voilà c'est un peu à
cause de calixte alors j'aime passer ses
grandes propositions de loi ça m'énerve
beaucoup
à fabriquer ce qu'avait savent open vous
avez fait de réponse et vous partez
quand quelqu'un de vous apporter la
contradiction c'est plus ça maintenant
non mais c'est pas une question de
contradictions non non non mais je sais
qu'elle est toujours à prendre des
positions extrêmes et ça me fatigue
terriblement bombe a coûté michel que
vous étiez venu un jour à une émission
sur tv5 on nous avait expliqué que je
vous étiez contre la contraception pour
les noirs parce que c'est une façon de
faire un génocide des noirs ça va
tellement exaspéré que depuis je veux
plus vous entendre on était contre la
contraception pour les noirs bah oui
parce qu'elle disait que c'était comme
janet permet il faut que les prolétaires
il faut que les prolétaires faisait
beaucoup ont fait mieux qu'au lac genre
mais décousu avec elle rit de tout à
l'heure je ne dis rien
voyez mais j'aimerais que vous allez
vous taire la mer merci le reste des
journaux de monsieur moi je n'ai jamais
dit ça c'est pas vrai monsieur vous le
regard donc je suis désolé c'était pas
ça je vous ai expliqué tout simplement
qu'on offre qui avait des régions on ne
pouvait pas développer l'économie à
coeur parce qu'ils avaient une
sous-population pourquoi au gabon et à
700 milles habitants avec ses 5000
habitants vous ne pouvez pas bâtir
réellement une économie à l'intérieur
des capotes qua non je n'ai pas dit ça
pas du tout il n'était pas question de
quatre partis de rien du tout mais vous
avez dit que l'afrique était surpeuplé
c'est ce que j'avais dit et c'est vous
qui avez raconté une grosse connerie
vous
je suis un divorce et supporte pas qu il
se confie je supporte pas c'est qu'à dix
médailles à ces que l face des livres
avec les livres des autres dit condamner
d'ailleurs c'est ce à quoi
et moi je ne devrais avoir honte à votre
place parce que vous êtes en train de
vraiment vous êtes vous montrer mais
vraiment je vous respecte elle
énormément et vous montrer d'une
médiocrité et l'isolément finalement
cédé que de l'apparence
ma mère maman ma mère bon reste que je
vous fais fisher sera pas drôle non mais
si c'est bon vous emmener comme ça
pendant toute la soirée effectivement
vous mais pas agresser je savais agressé
bah oui parce que justin est assez petit
bassin il a géré ça suffit vous savez ce
qui vous habite la haine de réfection
usa personne mais je respecte les
écrivains plus à partir de maintenant
non ça ne me dérange pas moi ça me
dérange pas de l'un d'eux
mes amis